,
SEAN PATRICK WE WILL HAVE MORE
ON HURRICANE IAN.
ALSO TONIGHT, VIOLENT CRIME
SPREADING WAY OUT OF CONTROL.
NEW YORK MAYOR ERIC ADAMS NOW
TOUTING HIS CITY'S SO-CALLED.
>> : MAKING FRONT OF GRILL
STATES ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
HERE'S A LITTLE PREVIEW OF WHAT
HIS BRANDED STATE LOOKS LIKE.
>> WE HAVE A BRAND.
NEW YORK HAS A BRAND.
AND WHEN PEOPLE SEE IT, IT MEANS
SOMETHING.
>> Sean: OKAY.
NEW YORK CITY HAS A BRANDED IS
THE SUBBRAND HERE, MR. MAYOR?
THAT YOU "-- YOU ARE REFERRING
TO.
DOES A WOMAN GETTING THE CRAP
BEAT OUT OF HER AND NEW CITY
SUBWAY, WE WILL SHOW YOU THE
FULL TAKE AND HIGHLIGHT THAT
BRAND OF ONE OF AMERICA'S MOST
UNLIVABLE CITIES.
PLUS WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THE
CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
TONIGHT.
ARIZONA SENATE CANDIDATE BLAKE
MASTERS WILL BE WITH US AND
SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY WILL ALSO BE
HERE REACTING TO FBI SWAT TEAM
STYLE RAID ON PRO-LIFE
ACTIVISTS.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH THE BIDEN
RECESSION THAT IS ABOUT TO GO
FROM BAD TO WORSE.
LOOK AT THIS BIG MORGAN STANLEY
CHIEF EQUITY STRATEGIST NOW
BELIEVES THAT A CORPORATE
EARNINGS RECESSION IS NOW LIVING
FOR THE COUNTRY WHICH IS
HORRIBLE NEWS FOR IMPORT
RETIREMENT.
HE IS PREDICTING THAT WE ARE
ABOUT TO EXPERIENCE SOMETHING
EVEN WORSE THAN A REGULAR
RECESSION.
STOCKS PLUNGING TO NEW LOWS
TRIGGERING WHAT HE IS CALLING AN
ECONOMIC CATASTROPHE.
AT THE CENTER OF BIDEN'S FAILING
ECONOMY, IT IS ENERGY, OIL, GAS.
IT GOES AFTER MONTHS OF
ATTEMPTING TO ARTIFICIALLY LOWER
THE PRICE AT THE PUMP BY
RECKLESSLY AND DANGEROUSLY
DRAINING AMERICA'S PETROLEUM
RESERVE.
THE COST PER GALLON OF GASOLINE
IS ON THE RISE ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY ONCE AGAIN.
SO NOW, JOE IS REVERTED BACK TO
LAST YEAR'S ENERGY STRATEGY AND
THAT IS DEMANDING THAT THEIR
STATIONS SIMPLY LOWER THEIR
PRICE.
AS IF THEY CAN.
PARTICULAR.
>> President Biden: GAS
COMPANIES WITH RECORD PROFITS.
BUT GUESS WHAT.
THE PRICE OF OIL WILL COME DOWN.
THE PRICE AT THE PUMP SHOULD
COME DOWN.
TO THE COMPANIES RUNNING GAS
STATIONS AND SETTING THOSE
PRICES, BRING DOWN THE PRICES.
YOU ARE CHARGING THEM -- DO IT
NOW.
DO IT NOW.
A MONTH FROM NOW, DO IT NOW.
>> Sean: IT DOES NOT APPEAR THAT
JOEY HAS A FIRM GRIP ON HOW
BUSINESSES ACTUALLY WORK OR THE
ENERGY SECTOR OPERATES.
RIGHT NOW, HE COULD LOWER GAS
PRICES, LIFT HIS OWN EXPIRATION
BAN.
HE COULD ALSO APPROVE MORE
PERMITS.
HE IS THE ONE THAT STOPPED
HE CAN REINSTATE OFFSHORE LEASE
SALES.
HE, WE START CONSTRUCTION ON THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE AND
EXPIRATIONS OF PRICES.
IF HE HAD NOT NEXT THE CRITICAL
PROJECT THAT THE XL PIPELINE, IT
WOULD ALREADY BE COMPLETE
ACCORDING TO ALBERTA PREMIER.
HE IS SAYING MAYBE PUMPING
900,000 BARRELS OF OIL INTO OUR
COUNTRY FROM CANADA EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
ALL JOE KILLED AMERICA'S VERY
OWN KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE, HE OF
COURSE AND EXPLICITLY LEFT ALL
SANCTIONS EVEN AS PUTIN AMASSED
TROOPS AT UKRAINE'S BORDER.
THIS PIPELINE APPARENTLY
SABOTAGED WITH UNDERWATER
EXPLOSIONS.
NATURAL GAS BUBBLES CAN BE SEEN
HERE LEAKING TO THE SURFACE.
BETWEEN PUTIN'S WAR IN UKRAINE
AND THIS ACT OF SABOTAGE.
BUT WELL, NORTH STREAMED TWO MAY
NEVER EVER BE OPERATIONAL TAKE
AT LEAST NOT FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE.
WHAT IS THE MORAL OF THE STORY?
WELL, WESTERN EUROPE NEVER
SHOULD HAVE GIVEN INTO THEIR
COMMENT ALARMISTS CALLED.
RUSSIA IS NOT A VIABLE SOURCE OF
ENERGY.
NEITHER IS VENICE WHETHER.
OR UKRAINE.
OR OPEC OR SAUDI ARABIA AND
CERTAINLY NOT IRAN.
THE U.S. IS A RELIABLE SOURCE OF
OUR OWN ENERGY NEEDS IF WE HAD
THE BRAINS TO DO IT.
WE COULD PRODUCE SAFER, CLEANER,
CHEAPER OIL AT -- AND GAS AND
COAL RIGHT HERE AT HOME.
WE CAN SUPPLY ALL OF OUR NEEDS
FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS AND EUROPE
AND SOLVE THEIR ENERGY NEEDS AND
HELP AMERICA GET RICH IN THE
PROCESS WHICH WOULD CREATE
UNTOLD NUMBERS OF HIGH PAYING
CAREER JOBS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IT WOULD ALSO BE GRATEFUL FOR
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
IT WOULD NOT BE DEPENDENT ON
COUNTRIES THAT HATE US FOR THE
BEST PART OF THE WORLD'S
ECONOMY.
WE COULD ALSO BUILD OUT OUR
EUROPEAN ALLIES WERE QUICK TO
OUR EXPECTANT HOME HEATING
PRICES TO JUMP A WHOPPING 200%
OR MORE THIS WINTER.
THEY ARE EXPECTING PEOPLE TO
FREEZE TO DEATH IN EUROPE THIS
YEAR.
BUT THERE'S A BIG PROBLEM.
JOE BIDEN AND HIS FELLOW
DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE STANDING IN
THE WAKE.
THEY ARE DETERMINED TO TURN OFF
THE SPIGOT, ALL IN THE NAME OF
SOME KIND OF GREEN NEW DEAL
FANTASY COAT UP BY THE RELIGIOUS
CLIMATE ALARMISTS CALLED.
NOW, POOR AND MIDDLE INCOME
AMERICANS, PEOPLE ON FIXED
INCOMES, THEY ARE THE ONES RIGHT
NOW IT'S GETTING HER THE MOST BY
JOE BIDEN'S ECONOMY.
BY THE EARTH ONCE STRUGGLING TO
PAY THEIR BILLS AND NOW YOU ARE
PUTTING THAT YOU LOOK AT
NECESSITIES ON CREDIT CARDS TO
PAY THEIR BILLS.
MORE THAN TWO-THIRDS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, LIVING PAYCHECK
TO PAYCHECK.
71% OF AMERICANS NOW CANNOT MAKE
IT ON THE SALARY THAT THEY ARE
TAKING CONCURRENTLY BECAUSE
ACCORDING TO HERITAGE
FOUNDATION, IT IS ABOUT $7,200
MORE A YEAR, PER HOUSEHOLD THAT
PEOPLE ARE PAINT BECAUSE OF
BIDEN'S INFLATION.
AND AS A RESULT, YOU KNOW,
EVERYTHING IS MADE WORSE WITH
THE DRAMATIC RISE IN INTEREST
RATES.
ON TOP OF THAT.
ON TOP OF THAT THAT WE HAVE A 40
YEAR HIGH INFLATION.
THAT IS GETTING RESPECT THIS IS
AN ECONOMIC NIGHTMARE FOR THE
AMERICAN MIDDLE CLASS, FOR POOR
AMERICANS AND BY THE WAY, JOE
CLAIMS HE HAS SO MUCH COMPASSION
FOR.
NO ONE IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SEEMS TO CARE
INSTEAD, THEY ARE OUT THERE
FOCUS ON MORE IMPORTANT ISSUES
LIKE RENAMING THE ATLANTA
BRAVES?
PROPERLY?
>> THE PRESIDENT HOSTING THE
ATLANTA BRAVES TODAY.
I WONDER IF YOU ARE THE
PRESIDENT HAS ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT
THE CONTROVERSIAL MEETING ABOUT
THAT TEAM NAME, THE BRAVES NAME,
THE SO-CALLED [INDISTINCT], ANY
THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> SO WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION.
WE SHOULD LISTEN TO NATIVE